my name is George Moses do you want to
be my friend no that's too creepy
sometimes in my hamburger research I
find one-off burgers and restaurants not
necessarily a regional specialty but a
specialty of the restaurant alone take
for example the Gunder burger from the
Irish shanty in Elgin Iowa or the
birdies special at the Shady Glen in
Connecticut these are specialty burgers
that really only exist at that one
location their fan favorites in some
cases fan favorites for a very very long
time
today I'm gonna teach you about a jet
but today I'm gonna today I want to
teach you about it tip today I'm gonna
teach you about a specialty burger it's
actually also pretty close to my home
it's from Brooklyn New York for Gargiulo
burger from a place called Brennan and
car Brennan a car is not a hamburger
joint it's actually a place that serves
hot sliced roast beef on rolls it's an
incredible place with lots of history
opened in 1938 think of a roast beef
sandwich a hot sliced roast beef
sandwich a beef patty on top of that
sliced amazing roast beef sauteed
Spanish onions two slices of American
cheese and then guess what
the whole damn thing gets dipped yeah
that's hot hot yes whole damn thing gets
dipped into a vat of beef broth ready to
cook let's do it I'm a preformed burger
patty fresh beef of course always onto
the flattop we've got a little bit of
salt
you wouldn't start with a pretty
good-sized patty because this thing is
gonna be going on to a very large hard
roll so this is not gonna be a Stef
wimpy burger there's a big burger 4 to 5
ounces probably a good size for this
burger okay now what I want to do also
is heat up some fresh slice this is this
is just deli roast beef if you would go
to Brennan a car they actually they
actually cooked their own roasts and
then slice it themselves and it's very
good
but for now they heat it up right next
to it
but 525 degrees there's some really cool
history behind this burger gar Shuler's
is a very fancy huge Italian restaurant
in Coney Island
Brenden car usually feeds the staff at
Gargiulo every Sunday
and instead of making everybody a
separate order that's a big step and
they would actually put out big buckets
of burgers and big buckets of roast beef
and they would actually bring their own
Italian bread to make sandwiches and a
couple of guys started putting a burger
patty and roast beef together on the but
on the same bun and the guards hula
burger with more
I usually preach the word of smash I'm
and I have a smash burger guy I love
smash burger so much I know that Seth
Rogen called
thick patty eaters [ __ ] it's I
understand where he's coming from I
don't totally agree with them because I
think everyone's gonna have their own
personal style their own personal
favorite for flipping burgers it's
gorgeous
okay so now we're gonna do is we're
gonna transfer the roast beef to the top
of the burger it's all contained there
there it is the roast beef on top of the
burger that is a beefy experience right
there sauteed onions two slices of
American cheese that's right
the Brenin car okay look at that thing a
beauty now to cover to melt the cheese
[Music]
sad back we're ready oh look at that but
we're not done yet you ready for this
one oh the Gargiulo burger is not done
yet we do next will blow your mind hope
you have a 5 quart at caldron of beef
broth in your house because I do yes
look at that
glorious beef broth okay just just like
at branding car the whole damn thing
goes into the Burrow oh [ __ ]
that's not supposed to happen we just
double dipped
Wow
the guard you little burger explosive
explosively beefy well oh yeah uh-huh
[Applause]
apparently oh my god mmm
deeply beefy very wet damn tasty and hot
as hell
who wants a bite takes your breath away
so did the other bike any other
questions hmm yes you can definitely
this is very true you really can find
incredible burgers an incredible burger
experiences and some of the most
unlikely places
hmm hmm suck in the corner nose tune
Avenue and Marine Park magar hula burger
a wet hot beefy mess like me
Oh
[Music]
so just yellow Lane also we're making a
little historical video about hamburgers
and I'm including the Gargiulo burger so
I got your blessing that's good okay I'm
gonna try to make one on camera almost
cry she's sorry
whoo I get emotional because that was
one of my hamburger heroes